♪ ♪
>> Laura: A NEW SEGMENT WITH
ONE OF OUR FAVORITE GUESTS,
CONGRESSMAN, WE ARE CALLING THIS
THE NEWS WHIP WITH THE MINORITY
WHIP WHICH IS CHEESY.
>> LET'S TRY IT OUT.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT
HOSTING A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
FOR NEGOTIATIONS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HERE WAS SOME OF THE REACTION
FROM BOTH PARTIES.
>> YOU WANT TO GET MONEY, BUILD
BRIDGES, HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> WILL HE BE ABLE TO DELIVER?
IN THE PAST HE OFTEN HAS SENT.
THERE IS WORK WE NEED TO DO WITH
ROADS AND BRIDGES.
>> THEY ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION WE HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: THEY WERE ALL
SMILING AND SO HAPPY COMING OUT
OF THAT MEETING.
I WAS NANCY PELOSI SOGETI?
WILL THEY BLOW 2 TRILLION ON
INFRASTRUCTURE?
>> HOW DO YOU PAY FOR IT?
IT IS TAXES.
THAT IS WHERE THEY WILL WANT TO
GO.
IT HAS TO BE PAID FOR, THAT IS
WHERE I THINK IT BREAKS DOWN.
>> Laura: LOOK AT NANCY PELOSI
NOW, THAT WAS TODAY.
LOOK AT HER SMILE VERSUS DURING
THE IMMIGRATION MEETING.
SHE WAS BITING HER LIP.
A TALE OF TWO NANCY'S.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
I GUESS THEY STARTED AT
1 TRILLION AND HE WAS LIKE LET'S
DO A 2 TRILLION.
WE ARE $22 TRILLION IN DEBT.
THERE CAN BE NO DEFICIT SPENDING
AND NO NEW TAXES AND THAT IS
WHERE IT BREAKS DOWN.
I THINK SHE IS SMILING BECAUSE
SHE GOT TO GET AWAY FROM THE
CAPITAL.
THEY HAVE BOGGED HER DOWN, THIS
MY RATE OF ANTI-SEMITISM,
SOCIALISM, THE BOSTON MARATHON
BOMBER BULGING.
>> Laura: THAT IS THE NEW
MORALITY.
AMERICA MORAL AGAIN.
CONGRESSMAN, SOME THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS LOOKING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR IMMIGRATION
TRADE.
WE WILL GIVE YOU INFRASTRUCTURE
AND YOU TO GIVE US SOME STUFF ON
IMMIGRATION.
A NEW POLL REVEALS THE
PERCENTAGE OF DEMOCRATS WAS TO
THE BORDER AS A CRISIS SHIPPED
17 POINTS IN JANUARY.
IF DEMOCRAT VOTERS ARE COMING TO
THIS CONCLUSION FINALLY THAT
THIS IS A REAL EMERGENCY, ALLOW
THE PRESIDENT HAVE TO NEGOTIATE
HERE?
>> MAY BE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
THE WALL.
PEOPLE GET THAT WE NEED TO
SECURE THE BORDER, REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, HOW DO YOU DO
THAT?
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME PHYSICAL
BARRIERS AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT WASHINGTON DEMOCRATS BY
PEOPLE ON THE MAINLAND OF THIS
COUNTRY WANT A SECURE BORDER AND
I KNOW THAT.
THEY KNOW THE DRUGS THAT ARE
COMING ACROSS ON THE VIOLENCE.
THEY SEE THIS CARAVAN.
>> Laura: CARAVANS.
>> Laura: ALL THE PROBLEMS IT
IS BRINGING AND ALL THESE
INTERIOR PROBLEMS, CATCH AND
RELEASE.
>> Laura: HOW DID 5G BECOME
INFRASTRUCTURE?
WE THOUGHT IT WAS A SHOVEL
READY.
WE HAVE TO MENTION
BERNIE SANDERS.
HE MENTIONED HE IS TRICKLING
DOWN TO GET THE FELONS TO VOTE
BUT IT DOESN'T END THERE.
>> AT A TIME WHEN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND DONALD TRUMP ARE
WORKING OVERTIME TO SUPPRESS THE
VOTE TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR, WE HAVE TO MAKE
IT CLEAR IN MY VIEW THAT IF YOU
ARE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN IF YOU
DO SOMETHING TERRIBLE WE CANNOT
TAKE AWAY YOUR RIGHT TO VOTE
WHETHER YOU ARE IN JAIL OR
WHETHER YOU LEFT JAIL.
CLEARLY WHAT REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING IS TRYING TO DENY PEOPLE
UP COLOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> Laura: THAT IS IT.
>> THAT IS THE MOST OFFENSIVE
THING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
CELEBRATING THE FACT THAT
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT IS
THE LOWEST IN HISTORY AND FERNIE
WANT TO CELEBRATE THAT.
HE WANTS TO GIVE FELONS AND
PRESENT THE RIGHT TO VOTE WHILE
THEY ARE IN PRISON.
WE ARE FOR EVERYBODY BEING ABLE
TO VOTE ONE TIME IN EACH
ELECTION AND THEY ARE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THOSE LAWS THAT
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE INTEGRITY
TO VOTE FOR EVERYBODY.
PROTECT EVERYBODY'S RIGHT TO
VOTE EXCEPT FELONS.
IF YOU ARE IN FEDERAL PRISON YOU
SHOULDN'T BE VOTING.
>> Laura: DO YOU KNOW
JOE BIDEN?
>> I HAVE MET THEM A NUMBER OF
TIMES.
>> Laura: HE DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THE OLD JOE BIDEN.
>> IF YOU HAD TO COMPETE IN THIS